bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du smartphone par extension de tout ce
qu'on peut faire avec de tout ce qu'on
va pouvoir faire avec
dans les années à venir parce que vous
voyez je prends l'exemple de samsung
avec son galaxy s ne fait même plus
et puis que d'autres produits notamment
les suites et compagnie on s'en fiche
peu importe les smartphones sont au
coeur de nos vies numériques mais ces
smartphones vont aller plus loin
puisqu'ils vont carrément prendre le
contrôle de votre vie en règle générale
en paille pilotait le contrôler et vous
soyez plus maître de rien du tout mais
vraiment être au centre de votre vie
numérique et notamment à la maison et
c'est ça qui est très intéressant je
voulais vous faire cette vidéo depuis
quelques temps il faut ça fait longtemps
que j'ai des trucs dans les tiroirs que
je voulais vous en parlait il ya peu de
temps
maintenant on va en parler nous emmener
avec moi on va retourner voyage et on va
tout d'abord à las vegas en faire un
bond dans le passé avoir tourné en
janvier dernier
[Musique]
ensuite on va aller à barcelone on va
aller au mwc directement dans les deux
cas sur le stand de samsung pour par les
objets connectés pour par les
smartphones du coeur de votre vie
numérique et voir tout ce que vous allez
pouvoir faire chez vous grâce à des
smartphones vous allez voir la
révolution arrive et elle a eu très très
rapidement et plus rapidement au point
de croix on y va
[Musique]
je conçois pas de questions de super
intéressant lan 10 100 cycles samsung et
on va parler effectivement ba2 les
objets collectés et comment est ce que
samsung arrive à connecter tous vos
objets améliorer votre vie vous avez un
smartphone connecté rick ce soit un
galaxy et suite s9 notre suite ou peu
importe vous avez votre gear votre monde
coller des sanctions oui avec ça vous
allez pouvoir aller beaucoup plus loin
alors vous et qui déjà vous allez
choisir votre part vous avez choisi à ce
que vous allez manger
vous avez le choix entre plusieurs
choses plusieurs plats que vous avez une
samsung est allé lui dire ce que vous
allez manger il en fit connaître vos
clones ensuite avec votre montre vous
avez effectivement faire du sport qui va
connaître votre dépense énergétique et
leur suis tout ça vous allez le
connecter directement avec votre
réfrigérateur
c'est à dire vous allez avoir un espèce
de con fil de votre vie qui va être
complètement complet c'est le cas de le
dire avec d'un côté ce que vous allez
manger va le savoir
de par votre réfrigérateur de par votre
four à côté
complètement connecté parce que sa
barque tout ça ce collègue dans le cloud
vous allez dans votre réfrigérateur
vous choisissez en fonction de ce que
vous avez acheté 2 choisissez ce que
vous allez cuisine et ensuite vous donne
tous la liste des ingrédients à acheter
si vous les avez pas trop compte était
une fois vous avez préparé ça va tomber
directement via globe à votre retour va
s'activer à des fonctions intelligentes
vous puissiez cuisiner en fonction sa
sanction pour ajuster complètement grâce
à un système intelligent vous reparle de
la guerre vous dire vous avez mangé ça
il ya tant de calories devriez aller
faire du sport
voilà ce que je vous conseille de manger
avec voilà ce que vous devriez manger
les autres jours pour équilibrer donc on
va plus loin on voit bien au niveau de
la santé collecté grâce aux objets
connectés et ça c'est super intéressant
avec vos outils que ce soit votre
smartphone votre montre votre four ce
que collective autre système qui est
super intéressant qu'elles soient bien
que les têtes samsung avec votre
téléphone avec votre note 8
principalement on peut l'imaginer aussi
avec ice cube dans la botte vous pouvez
écrire un message sur vos smartphones et
vous l'envoyez sur les objets collectés
de samsung que vous souhaitez plus de
traîner le riz par exemple son
réfrigérateur imaginons que vous disiez
vous voulez laisser un message à votre
compagne avec qui vous voulez à la
maison voulait envoyer mais ça se
finisse directement sur votre
réfrigérateur connectés
[Musique]
dormez sur le stand de samsung au mwc à
barcelone quand une vidéo qu'on a
commencé au csa las vegas pour parler
des objets connectés au tour de samsung
là avec le s9 on peut faire avec les
anciens avec la suite mais on va
continuer à aller plus loin vous pouvez
centralisée complètement votre intérieur
vous pouvez la piloter directement de
votre smartphone vous avez la dernière
télé connectée de samsung par exemple
vous pouvez complètement futile qui veut
smartphone vous pouvez piloter votre
réfrigérateur pour piloter votre plaque
de cuisson votre climatiseur on peut
aussi piloter votre robot pour passer
l'aspirateur fois il ya énormément de
possibilités et c'est ça qui est super
intéressant avec la solution de la
maison connectée de samsung parce qu'on
voit que l'intérêt et la stratégie de
samsung c'est pas juste envie d'entendre
un aspirateur de vendre un réfrigérateur
de nous vendre un dernier robot pour
nettoyer ou le dernier smartphone et la
mode c'est vraiment de prendre le
contrôle de votre vie numérique de
centraliser l'information directement
sur votre device sur votre smartphone et
de pouvoir tout piloté avec sap et on
voit qu'une fois qu'ils ont mis le pied
là dedans que vous avez commencé avec un
objet connecté vous allez acheter tout
le reste et vous équiper
de a à z samsung et les partenaires
samsung et pas partout samsung pour un
centre avec pas des gens tous là
philippe sou pour ça et c'est ça qui est
super intéressant qui tactiquement
passent quand on voit que c'est là où
ils ont un coup d'avancé par rapport
beaucoup d'autres marques c'est qu'ils
sont présents dans votre poche avec
votre smartphone ou votre tablette votre
ordinateur votre réfrigérateur votre
four la haute je ne sais pas la télé en
tout cas et c'est là où effectivement
ils ont une force de frappe et une vue
sur le long terme qui complètement
incroyable dites moi ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous pensez que ça ne
sonne je pourrais vous tentez vous en
tout cas sûr de la maison connectée
103-105 sung ils ont vraiment vraiment
longueur d'avancé par rapport aux autres
par rapport à apple même si
effectivement la solution de la maison
connectée apple est plutôt pas mal fichu
plutôt intéressante mais tous les
produits sont pas des produits apple
donc c'est là dessus au samsung ait une
vraie force de frappe marquis mavo
commentaire parce que moi français on en
discute
merci beaucoup vous avez rendez vous
très bientôt rester sage n'oubliez pas
abonné vous parce qu'on entendait
toujours plus de solutions
forcément innovantes non connectés
smartphones de votre vie numérique
et ça c'est super intéressant merci a
bientot ciao
[Musique]